tonight it is going to be loud around
the historic commercial center the plaza
near Maryland Parkway and Sahara as you
may know has been struggling for years
to bring it to life Clark County is
hosting a free concert but who's paying
for it how will thousands of people get
there with limited parking Lorna Grady
joining us live this morning with what
you need to know whether you're going or
if you're just going to be in the area
Lauren good morning
good morning you guys yes that's right
should be a great event here if you were
lucky enough to snag a ticket 12K people
1 1 000 parking spots only here to talk
more about it I'm joined by commissioner
Sager Bloom good morning good morning
okay so only a thousand parking spots
what should people know before they get
here
well first they should know that they
can get a ride share or have somebody
drop them off that's the best there will
be some parking and so if you have to
drive your car we'll find a place for
you but honestly it's going to be tight
but you know on that you're probably not
going to want to drive because there is
low
here you know drinks and food and music
talk more about what people should
expect when they get here well as you
can see there's gonna be there's three
different stages so they're going to
rotate from the different stages at the
end of the day it's going to be dead
mouse over here at this major stage
which is going to be really exciting a
major act but it's lots of little groups
Frankie Perez is going to be over here
lots of art lots of alcohol lots of food
lots of great restaurants so it's going
to be a real fun time and we're going to
cover more about the overarching why
revitalizing the area and just how
they're all paying for this whole thing
here for now live in the historic
commercial center Laura negretti 8 News
Now thanks so much Lauren looking
forward to that tonight we'll certainly
have complete